[Music]
hey everybody my name is chef Marcus
Samuelsson and these are my ten
essentials was born in Ethiopia was
adopted to Sweden went out three years
old it was really at my grandmother's
house where we really start to touch
food food has always been in my life by
the time I was 23 I became an executive
chef and I got three stars from York
Times by the way I dress sort of a story
of my life I always have something
African on me something sweetie so for
me the dressing is really an extension
of Who I am and what I do you know
perfect sushi for me it's like a perfect
meal it's the closest thing to go in
Japan but it has this Americana vibe
just the best on the Japanese world but
also the best of our way well friends
right I just love these these an
incredible artist and I learned English
opening up the CD and then looking at
the lyrics and just like Bob this is
what they're talking about a chef's
apron is really key to a chef never ever
have sort of spots on your apron
so in France we put up or apron
basically like this so we got really
messy over here and then when service
started we put it down like this
cooking is also Showtime customers can
come through your dining room any given
time these are my favorite converse as a
chef you're on your feet all day you can
do everything with them right
it's just comfortable it's also timeless
well a notepad so key for a chef at
least for me you know so much about
cooking is also writing down your
thought and creating this narrative you
know my uncle Torsten he had his
smokehouse where he smoked mackerel and
salmon so rather than just calling it
smoked salmon you know I put a name to
it omits all of sudden becomes a person
so I've used Twitter sometimes to
communicate out what great food what new
dishes or what special is coming on is
lie it's a very freshen of the chef he
was excited by staying things that is
fresh
mother-son relationship it's very
special it's classic the answer Ashima
will go on and then you gonna get a
little tussle she's gonna fight with the
phone what
hey DeMarcus get mum you're like yeah
it's just a daily check out Barbara is
something that you take smell everywhere
in Ethiopia it does two things for me
really first it makes me realize how
little I know about my Filipino heritage
and also make me think about how far
I've come
the rooster when I'm working is like a
great jazz tune with several different
notes with the people the layers of the
people is the key star the listener from
Kansas The New Yorker and then the last
star the challah mine and that's why I
always think about the rooster and how
magical it can be the red stripe is a
great sort of taste but it's also a vibe
to me
sometimes you can just be so simple a
good soccer match some good friends and
just having a beer thanks for watching
10 essential subscribe follow us on
Twitter common stay involved let us know
if you liked it thanks for watching
you
[Music]